Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Fluid simulation is a mature research field
within computer graphics with amazing papers
that show us how to simulate water flows with
lots of debris, how to perform liquid-fabric
interactions, and more.
This new project further improves the quality
of these works and shows us how thin, elastic
strands interact with oil paint, mud, melted
chocolate, and pasta sauce. There will be
plenty of tasty and messy simulations ahead,
not necessarily in that order, so, make sure
to hold on to your papers, just in case.
Here you see four scenarios of these different
materials dripping off of a thin strand. So,
why are these cases difficult to simulate?
The reason why it’s difficult, if not flat
out impossible because the hair strands and
the fluid layers are so thin, it would require
a simulation grid that is so microscopic,
or in other words, we would have to perform
our computations of quantities like pressure
and velocity on so many grid points, it would
probably take not from hours to days, but
from weeks to years to compute. I will show
you a table in a moment where you will see
that these amazingly detailed simulations
can be done on a grid of surprisingly low
resolution.
As a result, our simulations also needn’t
be so tiny in scale with one hair strand and
a few drops of mud or water. They can be done
on a much larger scale, so we can marvel together
at these tasty and messy simulations, you
decide which is which. I particularly liked
this animation with the oyster sauce because
you can also see a breakdown of the individual
elements of the simulation. Note that all
of the interactions between the noodles, the
sauce, the fork, and plate have to be simulated
with precision. Love it.
And now, the promised table. Here you can
see the delta x that means how fine the grid
resolution is, which is in the order of centimeters,
and not micrometers. That is reassuring, and
don’t forget that this work is an extension
to the Material Point Method, which is a hybrid
simulation method that both uses grids and
particles. And, sure enough, you can see here
that it simulates up to tens of millions of
particles as well, and the fact that the computation
times are still only measured in a few minutes
per frame is absolutely remarkable. Remember,
the fact that we can simulate this at all
is a miracle.
Now, this was run on the processor, and a
potential implementation on the graphics card
could yield us significant speedups, so I
really hope something like this appears in
the near future. Also, make sure to have a
look at the paper itself, which is outrageously
well written. If you wish to see more from
this paper, make sure to follow us on Instagram,
just search for Two Minute Papers there or
click the link in the description.
Now, I am still working as a full-time research
scientist at the Technical University of Vienna,
and we train plenty of neural networks during
our projects, which requires a lot of computational
resources. Every time we have to spend our
time maintaining these machines, I wish we
could use Linode. Linode is the world’s
largest independent cloud hosting and computing
provider. If you feel inspired by these works
and you wish to run your experiments or deploy
your already existing works through a simple
and reliable hosting service, make sure to
join over 800,000 other happy customers and
choose Linode. To reserve your GPU instance
and receivea $20 free credit, visitlinode.com/papersor
click the link in the description and use
the promo code “papers20” during signup.
Give it a try today! Our thanks to Linode
for supporting the series and helping us make
better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!